here in new york for a while yes i did
uh did you pay attention to the election
we've got a new mayor here bloomberg is
out i didn't even know there was an
election
i honestly don't i don't pay attention
at all i i
you know it's bankers get bonuses of
anywhere
the upper echelon get from like 10
million up to 100 million
and the president of the united states
makes like 400 grand a year
so right there i watched enough
wrestling to see a rigged game
and you know it's like people with
youtube channels making as much
as the leader of the free world so i
just think he's set up to be bribed
and uh you act accordingly so any
basically anybody who comes at me going
these these uh you know the conservative
right or you know
these liberals like i just zone out i
can't even talk to you if you're
actually still looking at it
like those are two choices that you're
getting you're not it's the same once
you get past a certain level it just
seems like it's
it's all the same yeah you've jumped in
the river and you act accordingly or you
get that convertible ride in dallas
now there's one thing you might have
noticed i don't complain about
politicians everybody complains about
politicians everybody says they suck
yeah well where do people think these
politicians come from
they don't fall out of the sky they
don't pass through a membrane from
another reality
they come from american parents and
american families american homes
american schools american churches
american businesses and american
universities
and they're elected by american citizens
this is the best we can do
folks this is what we have to offer
it's what our system produces garbage in
garbage out if you have selfish ignorant
citizens if you have selfish ignorant
citizens you're going to get selfish
ignorant leaders and term limits ain't
going to be any good you're just going
to wind up with a brand new bunch of
selfish ignorant americans so maybe
maybe maybe it's not the politicians who
suck
maybe something else sucks around here
like
the public yeah the public sucks
there's a nice campaign slogan for
somebody
the public sucks [ __ ] hope
[ __ ] hope because if it's really just
the fault of these politicians then
where are all the other bright people of
conscience
where are all the bright honest
intelligent americans ready to step in
and save the nation and lead the way we
don't have people like that
this country everybody's at the mall
scratching his ass picking his nose
taking his credit card out of his fanny
pack and buying a pair of sneakers with
lights in them
so i have solved this little political
dilemma for myself in a very simple way
on election day i stay home i don't vote
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him i don't vote
two reasons two reasons i don't vote
first of all it's meaningless
this country was bought and sold and
paid for a long time ago the [ __ ] they
shuffle around every four years
[Music]
doesn't mean a [ __ ] thing and
secondly i don't vote because i believe
if you vote
you have no right to complain people
like to twist that around i know they
say
they say well if you don't vote you have
no right to complain but where's the
logic in that
if you vote and you elect dishonest
incompetent people and they get into
office and screw everything up
well you are responsible for what they
have done you caused the problem you
voted them in you
have no right to complain i on the other
hand
did not vote who did not vote
who in fact did not even leave
the house on election day in
no way responsible for what these people
have done and have every right to
complain as loud as i want about the
mess you created that i had nothing to
do with
so i know that a little later on this
year you're going to have another one of
those really swell
presidential elections that you like so
much you'll enjoy yourselves it'll be a
lot of fun
i'm sure as soon as the election is over
your country will improve immediately
as for me i'll be home on that day doing
essentially the same thing as you
the only difference is when i get
finished masturbating
i'm going to have a little something to
show for it folks
thank you very much
[Music]
i really know who i'm gonna vote for
next time if things keep going the way
it's going is that gay dude
no mike pence
[Applause]
now this is the same club the punchline
this is 15 years ago
and i had just gotten back from from my
infamous uh
south africa trip and i came to the
punch line just cheering myself
up it's a safe place where i could tell
some jokes
and i find out that this comedian i know
chris tucker who's in all those rush
hour movies
i find out that chris is in san
francisco too at
some charity event so i call him like yo
i just saw you at some charity event
i said i'm doing a show at the punch
line why don't you come by the club
after your event is that cool dave i
thought she was dead [ __ ] i'll come by
he said
he says is it okay if i bring some
friends cause you know i'm with a lot
of people like man you chris tucker you
can bring whatever the [ __ ] you want
and then i show up to the club late that
night
i walk into the dressing room and sit in
the dressing room
is gavin newsom who at the time was the
mayor of san francisco
but now he's the governor of california
and sitting next to him was kamala
harris who at the time was the d.a of
san francisco
now she's a senator from california
that's front running on the democratic
ticket and sit next to her was
al gore
it's [ __ ] weird
sitting next to al gore was the guys
from google sergey and i don't know how
to say these
all right and it was chris tucker
and and ben jealous who at the time was
the president of the naacp
who was all just at this big charity
dinner and and
and paul moody was drinking scotch
and we all was just in there and you
know first i was a little uncomfortable
we start talking and
we all got along really well
at some point uh kamala harris says
she says to me she goes you know a
friend of mine is announcing
his candidacy for president tomorrow i
went to college with him
what i go barack obama she goes you've
heard of him
i'm like yo i just read about this dude
and she goes yo yeah
we talking she goes you know what she
says let's
let's call him on the phone i said what
the [ __ ]
and she picks the phone up and she downs
and she's listening like this
and she goes ah this is voicemail
and she gives me phone she goes leave me
a message
you know i didn't know what to say i
just said what you say to any black dude
is
running for president you know stay low
running his exact pattern this kind of
[ __ ]
and then the last thing i say is you
know what i said sir well i really do
believe you can do this like man i'm
wishing you luck
now next day i wake up and go for coffee
at a place called the embarcadero it's
like an eatery by the sea in san
francisco
and i'm walking to the coffee shop and
there's a police line and i can't cross
the tape but then i figured i have
[ __ ] i'm dave chappelle so i go into
the thing like this
and the police yoke me this
[ __ ] like tackle me immediately
and i see over the police shoulder
gavin newsom i couldn't remember his
name but i remember last the night
before i had kept
teasing him and saying he looked like
christian bale the guy from the batman
movies
uh so i see him and i can't remember
anything so much like
batman help
and he stops just like dave and and
and then the police see that the mayor
knows me so they're all like
oh sorry about that and he's like back
up everybody and he just picks me up
he's like i'm really sorry about that
i'm like i'm fine don't worry about it
and he's like he's like listen i'm here
with the prince would you like to meet
him i'm like i know prince that's my
[ __ ]
and we go around the corner and it was
prince charles the prince of england
i didn't know the protocol of meeting
royalty you're not supposed to touch
them i
dapped them up like a [ __ ] my [ __ ]
just hugging them and [ __ ] like this
dapping them up
and that [ __ ] was cool too that's
really [ __ ] weird
and then i was just out there in the
upside down not having no tv show trying
to figure life out
and the election was going on in the
background and this guy barack obama
was picking up steam this [ __ ]
was killing it
and i had a chance to go to the last
debate
on the democratic ticket and i went it's
me and chris tucker
sitting in myrtle beach south carolina
it's the last three candidates it was
barack obama
john edwards and hillary clinton now
obama is a lot taller than edwards and
clinton and he had the center podium
and at one point they're all on stage
and they start fussing and obama goes
look
none of us are perfect like this his
hands was like this and there was light
shining behind his head and the other
two candidates was looking up at the
[ __ ] and i was sitting in the audience
like
this [ __ ] looks like jesus
[Applause]
and i realized in that moment
that i was looking at the next president
of the united states i was certain of it
i couldn't explain it
but i knew what i was seeing and i got
really excited
and i'm not that kind of guy i said i
gotta meet this [ __ ]
so i stayed they were all on stage doing
interviews
and i just waited i was waiting and
waiting and then
john edwards was done with his
interviews first because everybody knew
he wasn't going to win
uh and i see john edwards and i said hey
hey
senator edwards i just want to say hi
and that [ __ ] looked like
[ __ ] even [ __ ] you gonna lose anyway
and then he left and then hillary
clinton just walked by me and won them
steve harvey suits
but obama was taking forever
everybody wanted to talk to him when i
knew the media saw exactly what i
saw there was no question about it dad
was the guy i waited and i waited
and finally must have been over an hour
and a half he finishes his last
interview he was like
thank you very much good to talk to you
and he turns around
and he's we make eye contact he sees me
and when he sees me he looks up he goes
dave chappelle
and and obama did me the same way i did
prince charles
he like bro hugged me and he pulled me
in and i'll never forget this he said in
my ear
i got your message thank you very much
good night
you